So these creatures engaging in dominance
disputes and,
and I think dominance is the right way
to think about it because lobsters
aren't very empathic and they're not
very social.
And so it really is the toughest lobster
that wins,
you know,
and what's so cool about the lobster is
that when a lobster wins,
he flexes and gets bigger.
So he looks bigger because he's a
winner.
It's like he's advertising that and the
biological,
the neurochemical system that makes him
flex his serotonergic and you think,
well,
who cares?
What the hell does that mean?
Well,
tell you what it means.
It's the same chemical that's affected
by antidepressants in human beings.
And so like,
if you're depressed,
you're defeated lobster.
Like you're like this.
I'm small,
I'm not,
you know,
things are dangerous.
I don't want to fight.
You give somebody an anti depressants
like cup they stretch and then they're
ready to like take on the world again.
Well,
if you give lobsters who just got
defeated in a fight,
Serotonin,
then they stretch out and they'll fight
again.
And that's like we separated from those
creatures on the evolutionary timescale.
Somewhere between 350 and 600 million
years ago and the damn neurochemistry is
the same,
and so that's another indication of just
how important hierarchies of authority
are.
I mean,
they've been conserved since the time of
lobsters,
right?
There were trees around when lobsters
first first manifested themselves on the
planet.
And so what that means is these
hierarchies that I've been talking
about,
those things are older than trees.
And so one of the truisms for what
constitutes real from a Darwinian
perspective is that,
which has been around the longest period
of time,
right?
Because it's had the longest period of
time to exert selection pressure.
Well,
we know we evolved and lived in trees,
something on the order of 60 million
years ago.
We're talking 10 times as far back as
that for the hierarchy.
And so the idea that human beings that
the hierarchy is something that has
exerted selection pressure on human
beings is I don't think that's a
disputable.
That's not a disputable issue.
How it's done at an exactly what that
means we can argue about,
but like that sort of biological
continuity is just absolutely
unbelievable.
I,
um,
it was funny because I revealed this
finding,
you know,
I didn't discover this,
I read about it,
but I talked to my graduate students
about,
I used to take them out for breakfast,
you know,
and they were very contentious,
snappy bunch and uh,
and they're always trying to one up each
other and they were quite witty and for
like six months until it got very
annoying.
Every time one of them went up the
other,
they'd stretch themselves out,
like snap their hands.
Like.
So that was,
that was very funny.
It was,
it was really very funny.
So you see this in lobsters and so
that's pretty amazing.
So,
you know,
and one of the other thing that's really
cool about lobsters is that,
um,
let's say you've been like top lobster
for a long time,
but you're getting kind of old and some
young lobster just,
you know,
whales the hell out of you.
And so you're all depressed,
but thing is your brain is dominant,
but you don't have much of a brain
because you're a lobster.
And so now what are you going to do?
Because you just lost.
And the answer is while your brain will
dissolve and then you'll grow a
subordinate brain.
Yeah.
And so that's where thinking about too,
right here,
for a couple of reasons.
First of all,
if any of you who've ever been seriously
defeated in life,
you know what that's like.
It's like it's a death,
a dissenter,
a dissolution,
and if you're lucky,
a regrowth and,
and maybe not as the same person,
that's what happens to people with
posttraumatic stress disorder,
right?
Their brains undergo permanent
neurological transformation and,
and they then inhabit a world that's
much more dangerous than the world that
they inhabited to begin with.
But we also know too,
if you have posttraumatic stress
disorder or depression,
that your hippocampus shrinks,
right?
He dies and shrinks,
and you can sometimes get it to grow
back.
Your hippocampus shrinks and your
Amygdala and the Amygdala increases
emotional sensitivity.
And the hippocampus inhibits emotional
sensitivity.
And so if you've been badly defeated,
the hippocampus shrinks and the amygdala
grows.
Now if you recover,
the hippocampus will regrow.
And antidepressants actually seem to
help that.
But the damn Amygdala never shrinks
again.
And so well.
So that's another lesson from the
lobster.
It's quite a terrifying one,
but,
but it's one like,
it's so interesting that you can relate
to that.
Right.
I was like,
I get what that poor crustaceans going
through,
you know.